mein name ist und das ding der holocaust
aber hätten das gab es so viele
anschläge vom ausgang der partie ferkel
mittleren bomben machen
da sieht man ein rohr mit verschlossen
da gibt's auch anleitungen zu so dachte
ich das gleich sind ja eigentlich ein
gebrochener also wird vielleicht theo
angebrochen und da geht rein und dann
total schießen und zu abwarten ab märz
in rechte terror verändert sich auch in
deutschland er wird schneller und kommt
scheinbar aus dem nichts mein name ist
anders der holocaust erwarten
was wäre wenn er durch die tür hindurch
gekommen wären wäre ich noch am leben
männlich weiß gescheitert der hass von
rechten terroristen richtet sich gegen
juden muslime und andersdenkende
menschen wie stefan basiert neben den
tod anderer in kauf aus angst vor dem
fremden doch warum morgen sie amokläufer
sind menschen die alles bündeln wollen
auf den augenblick wo sie endlich herr
über leben und tod sind wo sie die panik
in den augen der opfer sehen
er führte ein leben zwischen rassenhass
digitaler strukturen und selbstgebaute
waffen
wer eine solche tat begehen möchte wer
das notwendige rüstzeug dafür haben
möchte der kann sich das in deutschland
ungehindert beschaffen wie das rechtlich
kontrolliert werden soll darauf an
behörden und politik bis heute keine
antwort
[Musik]
bendorf ein kleiner ort bei eisleben im
harz hier steigt stephan pariert am 9
oktober 2009 10 mit einer action cam an
seinem körper ins auto und fährt 40
kilometer nach halle um 11 uhr 57 postet
er auf der gaming plattform twitter
einen link zum stream seiner helmkamera
in seinem mietwagen liegen acht waffen
mit mehr als 1300 schuss munition fünf
menschen verfolgen angeblich live was
stephan pariert in den nächsten 36
minuten macht roman -remis hat den
anschlag miterlebt er fährt einmal pro
woche nach halle um den jüdischen
gottesdienst zu führen wir treffen ihn
in seiner heimatstadt berlin ein halbes
jahr nach dem anschlag
ich mag das ja dort zu sagen hatte es
eine schöne gemeinde gemeindemitglieder
sind wirklich meine freunde geworden ich
kenne sie schon seit langem sie jetzt im
jänner geschichten wie es früher war
das mag ich es in halle und ich war
vielleicht auch eigentlich ja ist eine
schöne kleine stadt ein bisschen
spazieren gehen und sagen wir gesagt
geschrieben
[Musik]
der morgendliche schön daran nicht also
es war ein sonniger tag ich war an dem
zeitpunkt noch im hotel also ich habe
mir ein hotel übernachtet um die ecke
herum gehen nach draußen alles so schön
man geht man auf eine synagoge und die
leute sind schon da und man bereits für
das gebet vorm wald das gebiete sei lang
und deshalb davor haben sich dann auch
und die zeit genommen die noch mal zu
unterhalten und noch ein bisschen social
eisen und dann begann das gebet und der
teil wurde sagen wo der anschlag
passiert ist das war der teil zwischen
zwei wichtigen gebeten uns war ein teil
wo vorgelesen wurde aus dem alten
testament ist ein ruhiger und die
menschen mal noch etwas entspannter sage
ich nur unterwegs und dann die schalter
knallen
[Musik]
mit seinen selbst gebauten waffen
versucht der attentäter in die synagoge
einzudringen
in der sich etwa 50 gläubige aufhalten
fünf zuschauer sehen angeblich live wie
bei stephan pariert nichts nach plan
bericht wir machen lacht wir haben noch
gesungen haben das gebiet zu ende
gemacht habe mich umgedreht und blickte
auf den sicherheitsmann macht die kamera
als auf dem bildschirm dahinter man
sagen auch nicht so gut dass man sei
nichts ungewöhnliches aber sie sich erst
mal meinte gerade da ist eine person
draußen und dann guckte ich auf den
orten die ganze gemeinde erstellen dann
gucken wir auf den gemeine vorsitzenden
der meinte zu uns wer ist denn da weil
wir sind keine gemeinde sind wissen wenn
wir da sein müsste und wer nicht und
alle die da sein müssten waren schon
drin deshalb war es ungewöhnlich dass
jetzt noch irgendjemand draußen war und
dann sagen wir den attentäter in
blatzheim und tor
er wirft selbst gebaute bomben über die
mauer als jana l die straße entlang geht
im vorbeigehen schimpft sie
dass er aufhören soll stephan pariert
schießt der 40 jährigen mehrmals in den
rücken
bis zum zeitpunkt wo der attentäter weg
war war es nicht klar was passiert ist
so er später habe ich gesagt leute das
wir haben gerade einen terror anschlag
überlebt und daten täter dabei eine
person anscheinend umgebracht die liegt
doch gerade draußen und wir bleiben aber
erst mal drinnen
der attentäter scheitert an der tür
deshalb sucht er sich ein neues ziel
und niemand hält ihn auf verliert
schießt auf passanten dringt in einen
döner imbiss ein und tötet den 20
jährigen kevin es aus merseburg erst
jetzt stellt sich die polizei ballett in
den weg und wird beschossen
mittlerweile ist er am hals verletzt
sein bild wagen hat einen platten
trotzdem schaffte es der polizei zu
entkommen die polizei verliert den
terroristen für mehr als eine stunde
wenige minuten später wird er die
helmkamera aus dem seitenfenster nachdem
er auf der flucht ein taxi kaperte und
auf der autobahn richtung leipzig einen
unfall baute wurde er erst um 13 35
festgenommen für die freunde und
familien der opfer bleibt nur trauer und
kummer lehre und verzweiflung eine davon
ist manuela eine gute freundin von jan l
[Musik]
ich kann es nicht begreifen dass gerade
sie betroffen hatte dass er lang
gelaufen es wird die heute nach hause
das müsste ich das ungewohnte aber dass
sie gerade dem moment wo das passiert
dass sie gerade darauf dass obwohl
worden ist sie hat sich diese natürlich
falsch eingeschätzt wird
das kann doch nicht wahr sein
fabian sie war kurz davor zu hause in
ihre wohnung
ich verstehe die leute um klinger leute
die sind ja nicht schon weiter gelaufen
als ich mich dann schon damit und cooper
das hat ein mann hatten viele vier
anschlägen
direkt vor der haustür hat mit ihrem
dachte dass wir gleich heute sterben
werden das war weil er ebenso
ego-shooter mäßig unterwegs war und
dachte ich das gleiche ritual ein
gebrochener also wird gleich die tür
eingebrochen und da geht rein und dann
totale schießen und so abwarten absetzen
und das ist das interessante das von
drinnen aus so wo ich auf den bildschirm
geschaut habe kam man sich sehr sicher
erfolg haben sie wirklich sehr
zielorientiert fahren und ein später
sieht man seiner sicht was er gesagt hat
und wie die teile nervöser war und was
und alles hat funktioniert und das ganze
bild wurde erst klar für mich wo wir
rausgegangen sind wurden ausgeführt vom
sek dann sage ich wirklich dieses
kriegsgebiet wurde jede straße
abgesperrt waren stephan pariert wuchs
in bendorf aus die gemeinde bei
lutherstadt eisleben hat gerade mal 2000
einwohner laut bild -informationen war
er schon immer ein außenseiter
eine freundin hatte er nie er machte
sein abitur mit der note 2,8 begann
sogar ein chemiestudium eine
darmkrankheit warf ihn aus der bahn
danach lebte der 28 jährige wieder hier
mit seiner mutter die schuld für seine
situation gab er immer den anderen
bild traf den vater von stephan pariert
noch am tag des anschlags die eltern
trennten sich als ballett 14 jahre alt
war
sein sohn soll ein eigenbrötler gewesen
sein viel an seinem computer gesessen
haben
er sei schon lange nicht mehr zu ihm
durch gekommen erzählt der vater
wenn der kindheit entsteht der hass aus
der un- macht sehr entscheidend ist für
die entwicklung einer rechtsextremen
gewalt orientierung welche freunde mann
im alter von 14 15 16 findet die
konstante bei den rechtsextremen
gewalttätern ist dass sie eine kindheit
verunsichert worden sind und aus dem
freundschafts gefühle die man
unterdrücken muss und dann koordiniert
das immer weiter und wenn man dann in
der klasse oder in der gruppe in der
freizeit irgendwo einen sieht der sich
eignet als hassobjekt wie zb der jude
der mandelbaum heißt und in der schule
in derselben schule ist das sind da nur
fremde und dann bündelt sich der hass
gleich gegen die weil es ja alles was
fremd ist erstmal ein objekt ist von
ängsten und dann voll hass verschwörungs
ideologien und rassismus gedeihen auch
im netz aber wer sind die drahtzieher im
alltag sind sie unscheinbar in
berlin-marzahn treffen wir mit
versteckter kamera den gründer und admin
der telegramm gruppe deutsche patrioten
im echten leben arbeitet er als ein tier
in seiner chat gruppe hetzt er gegen
ausländer
inzwischen hat sich um die sichtweise
der rechten verändert naja ich bin ja
selber ausländer ungarischer
staatsbürger
nein und mit juden habe ich gar nichts
gemein
der gründer der sich hans nennt geht
sogar so weit dass er im gespräch den
holocaust leugnet es gab erschießungen
hoher an juden ja aber vergasungen 9
in seiner telegramm gruppe deutsche
patrioten herrscht so ein rassistisches
und vor allem juden feindliches klima
hans aus marzahn hat die telegramm
gruppe gegründet um rechten
gleichgesinnten eine plattform zu geben
genau solche verachtenden theorien
ungehindert und anonym zu verbreiten
ich bin mir bewusst dass da noch ein
feindbild bist du natürlich so in diesen
so unter den top ten listen wir
versuchen so den hintergrund zu
verstehen was hat ein mensch mehr zu
bewegen sondern tat zu begehen
ich habe die meisten wollen das
verstehen des wegen des attentäters
wurde live angeblich von fünf menschen
angesehen das video wurde erst nach
sechs stunden gelöscht
und bereits auf anderen plattformen und
in telegramm gruppen von gleichgesinnten
geteilt und gespeichert insgesamt wurde
es über 2500 mal angesehen und es bis
heute online
der mann den wir mit versteckter kamera
in marzahn treffen hat das video in
seiner telegramm gruppe auf verachtende
weise kommentiert macht sich sogar
darüber lustig bilanz des misserfolgs
schießt nach vier versuchen nur den
türgriff ab ist nicht in der lage ein
gartentürchen aufzutreten
fummelt dilettantisch munition in die
schrotflinte und nicht nur das er prallt
sogar damit solche selbstgebauten waffen
besser machen zu können
das klappt doch aber sowas testet man
vorher
dann fährt man in den wald testet man
probiert man es funktioniert was nicht
was für eine sprengkraft hat das was ich
mir gerade zusammen warst
wenn ich so etwas machen würde würde ich
es so machen wenn ich zum beispiel
bomben bauen wollen würde und die testen
wollen würde
da mache ich das silvester rohrbomben
machen damit man ein rohr mit
verschlossen da gibt's auch anleitungen
zu
und davon gibt es im netz mehr als genug
stephan pariert benutzte ausschließlich
selbst gebaute waffen eine davon ist die
waffe nach dem modell des engländers
philip luther die lud die
maschinenpistole ist ursprünglich
entstanden als politischer protest gegen
dürfen verboten großbritannien
zielgerichtet sollte eine waffe
entwickelt werden die mit einfachsten
materialien zu einer maschinenpistole
zusammengestellt werden konnte die
tatsächlich vollautomatisch feuert und
natürlich das potenzial hat auch
tödliche verletzungen herbeizuführen
wer töten will kann sich also jeder zeit
eine waffe und passende munition bauen
oder ausdrucken egal wie sehr die
regierung die waffengesetze verschärfen
[Musik]
komplette baupläne etwa für die luther
gibt es im netz
dort hat stefan verliert seine anleitung
gefunden
diese waffe gehört mit zu den simpelsten
maschinen personen die sich in
eigenarbeit herstellen lassen sodass es
naheliegend gewesen ist für den stefan b
diese waffe auch selbst zu fertigen für
seine tat außen punkt zu verwenden
das kann tatsächlich jeder schüler
selbst zu hause in eigenarbeit
herstellen solche selbstgebauten waffen
wie sie der attentäter benutzt hat
beobachtet der waffenexperte lars
winkels dorf schon lange mit sorge zwar
hatten die waffen des attentäters
fehlfunktion und blockierten aber das
wesentliche ist dass alle teile die für
die herstellung einer waffe benötigt
werden im baumarkt vollkommen frei zu
kaufen sind
und stephan pariert hat er ein ganzes
arsenal auf selbstgebauten waffen und
sprengsätzen die auf der werkbank seines
vaters zusammen getüftelt hat eine
improvisierte schrotflinte eine
sogenannte slam besteht lediglich aus
zwei rohren und einer schraube
[Musik]
die wesentlichen bestandteile dafür
bekam er maßgeschneidert direkt aus dem
baumarkt
[Musik]
da haben wir im grunde schon das
wesentliche teil was wir brauchen für
die herstellung einer schusswaffe
nämlich unseren lauf diese rohre sind
genormt von ihren dimensionen her und
interessanterweise so genormt das
problemlos eine schrotpatronen
hineinpasst wenn wir das entsprechend
kürzen versehen das mit einem gewinde
haben wir den grundbestandteil eine
selbst gefertigte schusswaffe für die
herstellung einer maschinenpistole wie
etwa am beispiel halle brauche ich
natürlich auch entsprechende kleinteile
für den abzug mechanismus für den lade
mechanismus und da bietet sich im grunde
solches recht ideal an hier kann ich
tatsächlich meine kleinen teile einfach
ausschneiden mit der feile fertig
bearbeiten und gebrauchsfähig in die
waffe einbauen
es ist also verhältnismäßig einfach und
wir finden wirklich überall die teile
die wir benötigen um solche
funktionierenden schusswaffen auch
herstellen zu können
beim attentäter von halle wurde außerdem
ein 3d drucker bleischrot und
metallwaren gefunden damit hat er sich
teile seiner waffe ausgedruckt waffen
bastler tauschen erweitern und
verbessern solche anleitungen für
waffenteile magazine und hülsen und
stellen sie ins netz fakt ist
deutsche behörden können nicht wissen
wer sich eine waffe selbst baut und wie
viele es schon davon gibt verhindern
ließe sich der eigenbau nur wenn
sämtliche werkzeuge der metall- und
kunststoffverarbeitung samt den
baumärkten verboten werden würden
am beispiel von stephan pariert bedeutet
dass die toleranzen in der er selbst
gefertigten waffe waren so hoch dass die
funktion nicht mehr gewährleistet war
mit etwas mehr sachkenntnis mit etwas
mehr sorgfalt wäre hier weitaus mehr
geschehen diese waffen wären weitaus
funktionsfähiger gewesen es ist
glücklicherweise der unfähigkeit des
täters zu verdanken dass nicht noch mehr
menschen ums leben gekommen sind
was wäre wenn also immer was wäre wenn
er durch die tür hindurch gekommen wäre
was wird wenn er drinnen im raum gewesen
wäre
werden wir überleben würden jetzt
zurückkämpfen wenn wir wäre ich noch am
leben
ich bin ein religiöser menschen ist
unglaublich das war gott gewollt ist das
nicht passiert ist ich glaube das ist
ein wunder
miro dietrich recherchiert seit jahren
verdeckte in rechtsextremen online foren
und gruppen genau in solchen
abgeschotteten räumen in denen der
attentäter stephan pariert seinen
bekennerschreiben hochgeladen hat der
halle täter burg für mich jetzt nicht
wie ein intellektueller der
unterbeschäftigten ich glaube eher dass
eine politische überzeugung dass er über
- entstanden
aber wer texte die kurzen sachen die
online gelesen hat aber jetzt nichts
kompliziertes aber wie kann es sein dass
er nicht auf dem schirm der polizei war
das sind nicht leute die jeden festen
rechtsextremen strukturen sind sondern
die in der öffentlichkeit ein ganz
normales bild abgeben die sich aber
online in diese rechtsextremen
radikalisierung frauen zurückziehen
die ideologische teilnimmt ab also noch
ganz kurz vorm leute erklären warum sie
es eigentlich machen dafür steigt der
handlungsorientierte teil also wie
wollen sie vorgehen was sind ihre waffen
also die tat rückt den vordergrund
weniger die motivation der tat wo es
eben darum geht verherrlicht werden
stephan barth 11 seitiges
bekennerschreiben liest sich wie eine
anleitung für ein spiel bei dem in einer
bestimmten zeit eindeutige ziele
erreicht und das heißt getötet werden
müssen
wer einen juden umbringt bekommt ein
sogenanntes cat girl als belohnung eine
frau mit katzen in der anklageschrift
die bild vorliegt geht hervor dass er
genau solche bilder von japanischen
comic mädchen sammelte oft auch in
knappen nazi uniformen angezogen
inzwischen sind die gängigen plattformen
ziemlich gut darin rechtsextreme inhalte
zu löschen
aber wer zu extrem ist wandert einfach
ab auf plattformen auf denen kaum etwas
reguliert oder gelöscht wird
vor zehn oder tweets hier landet er auch
der livestream von stephan pariert
miro dietrich hält aber auch die
gängigen plattformen für gefährlich
stichwort algorithmus das haben sehr
viele untersuchungen gezeigt dass der
algorithmus einen radikalisiert auch bei
und politischen themen etwa wenn man
joggen gegeben ein gegeben hatten ist
man irgendwie sehr schnell zu lange
strecken marathon gelernt wird
vegetarier sind zu veganern videos
gelangen also kasseler inhalte werden
dann vorgeschlagen und kann man sich für
die schule über irgendwas informieren
über ein thema und über mehrere klicks
wenn er in sachen vorgeschlagen dann
landet man dann irgendwelche
rechtsextremen verschwörungstheorien und
wenn der algorithmus dann einmal das
profil von einem gelernt hat schlägt
dann natürlich immer das vor
und dann sieht man eigentlich ist man
sehr schnell in einer welt die nur noch
aus rechtsextremer ideologie und
verschwörungen besteht
nach der amokfahrt von stephan pariert
untersuchte der experte vor allem die
chat plattform telegramm wo auch der
live stream geteilt wurde
ganz einfach die plattform die absolut
gar nicht gegen rechtsextreme inhalte
vorgeht auch falls terror inhalte sind
also ein video eines terroranschlags in
dem fall menschen sterben ist der
plattform erreicht der plattform ich das
gelöscht wird
man kann beiträge auch melden
ich habe es damals natürlich nach gewalt
gemeldet aber es ist heute nach online
ansonsten aufrufe zu gehen und sieht man
namen und adressen für leute mit mord
aufrufen
ferner dort ganz auf der stadt für den
kriminologen pfeiffer ist stefan bald
ein vereinsamter junger mann ohne
perspektive der sich hier aufgehoben
gefühlt hat die wurzel für seinen hass
liege aber viel tiefer amokläufer sind
menschen die extreme und macht erlebt
hatten und die alles bündeln wollen auf
den augenblick wo sie endlich herr über
leben und tod sind wurde die panik in
den augen der opfer sehen wo sie um sich
ballern und den frust loswerden der sich
bei ihnen angestaut hat als ein sozial
verlierer diese meistens sind als jemand
der hassgefühle entwickelt hat gegen
eine bestimmte gruppe und der sich stark
fühlen möchte wenn er das problem löst
nun muss sie stephan pariert für seine
taten vor gericht verantworten er ist
unter anderem wegen zweifachen mordes
angeklagt dazu kommen versuchter mord
volksverhetzung und körperverletzung im
gefängnis roter ochse in halle wartet
der attentäter auf seinen prozess
also mit dem prozess habe ich bin auch
nicht so stark befasst wahrscheinlich
bewusst gewisse panik habe ich von dem
gedanken dass er frei kommt
eigentlich dürfte der attentäter seine
kamera überwachte zelle nicht ohne
aussicht verlassen
trotzdem gelangen ihm am pfingstsamstag
ein fluchtversuch wegen einer
justizpanne verliert schaffte es sogar
den zaun seines freistunden hofes zu
überklettern und war mehrere minuten
unbeaufsichtigt
das von kranken sein wie er selber sich
jetzt so wahrnimmt
er klammert sich an die richtigkeit
seines handelns fiebert dem prozesstag
entgegen wo er gefragt wird und dann und
festhält an seinen überzeugungen und
hofft seine zeugenaussage wird
wahrgenommen in der rechten szene und er
wird ein held
laut süddeutscher zeitung hatte er
bereits umfassend ausgesagt dass er die
tat zwar bereue
allerdings nur weil er damit zu wenige
menschen und auch noch die falschen
getötet habe also wenn ich gegenüber von
dem attentäter sitzen würde ich ihm
sagen was ist los mit dir wie so was
habe ich dazu gebracht dass solche tat
begehen musste ist also jedes vor dir
kommt mir ich bin ein mensch ich möchte
ich mich nicht umbringen ich möchte hier
eigentlich
ich möchte dass du normales leben hast
möchtest du einen job hast desto familie
kinder ist alles was man sich wünschen
kann finde ich weiß da also das wünschen
geht menschen das haben wir die angetan
das ist so wichtig sind kunden also das
wirklich sich bereit erklärt hat solche
tat zu begehen
ein sachverständiger attestierte eine
komplexe persönlichkeitsstörung die
untersuchung ergaben eine misstrauische
selbstbezogene und unsichere person
wahrscheinlich voller blindem hass
[Musik]
die grundstücke sind bei 12 durchsuchen
und wie sichergestellt worden
was schönes zimmer seine freiheiten
[Musik]